sure I've heard the advice unplugging is
good for the mind the body the soul but
hey so is having no unread emails I'm
looking at Instagram all day but the
summer I vowed to spend more of my
vacation and weekend time with the
screens off I didn't go cold turkey not
that crazy but I am using my tech to
control my time using tech here's how
and you thought parental controls were
just for kids don't worry you're not
gonna be seeing me on a TLC special
about adult babies but I have been using
the apps to set up screen limits for
myself
for my week off I decided to give myself
90 minutes throughout the day a new
iPhone app for adults called moment
tracks how much time you spend on your
iPhone every day and allows you to set
limits when you hit that mark it will
play the most annoying sound in the
world but a parental control iPhone app
called parental time lock was far better
at accounting for every moment I spent
on my phone it also displays your
remaining time right on the app icon and
when the time is up it locks you out for
Android I liked a similar app called
screen time you'll obviously know the
unlock password unlike your kids but the
point is time awareness if you're really
lacking self-discipline you could always
have someone else set it up for you
Joanna
that's enough tablet time for today but
mom the Kim Kardashian game the second
thing I did was remove her high the
distractions on my phone or tablet yes I
almost had a small panic attack when I
turned off the email and Twitter push
notifications but it was liberating not
to hear the constant chime of a new
message I also moved my email app off
the front page of my phone and even did
the unthinkable I deleted Twitter and
Instagram
entirely
it's been 24 hours since I left
Instagram or Twitter doing ok the
shaking is subsided of course nobody
even noticed I was gone which brings up
one of the many reasons some of us are
scared to unplug well anyone care if we
just vanish lastly when all those
digital barricades were set up i subbed
my phone for some analog devices i read
a real book with pages you have to turn
not swipe i wore a watch so i wouldn't
check my phone for the time and i used
an alarm clock so my phone didn't end up
in my hand first thing in the morning
but replacing the camera and the music
player on my phone was harder yeah
some experts would say that i should
fully disconnect but over the last week
i found a really good balance of online
and offline time using these tools and
apps but now you just have another major
problem vacation time limit has been
reached